einmal zunächst mal die Klärung was
genau ist eine taktische Atomwaffe es
entsteht ja manchmal sogar Eindruck im
Diskussion auch auch hier in der Sendung
naja da gibt es diese ganz bösen diese
großen Atomwaffen und dann gibt es diese
taktisch naturwaffen
Wirkungsradius vielleicht 100 km und so
weiter das wäre schlimm aber das wäre
etwas was man durchaus überstehen könnte
teilen Sie diese Meinung
also da geht schon auch einiges
durcheinander ich spreche eigentlich
eher von Gefechtsfeld Waffen wenn andere
taktische Waffen sagen warum weil in
diesem Wort ist eigentlich schon
angelegt was für eine Art von Waffe das
ist nämlich die sollen tatsächlich eine
Wirkung auf dem Gefechtsfeld haben
und deswegen sind sie in der Regel auch
mit einer etwas geringeren
sprengenwirkung unterwegs und in der
Regel werden sie auch mit Trägersystem
verbracht die nicht ganz so weit fliegen
das ist aber der Grund es ist nicht so
dass man sagt strategisch Nuklearwaffe
große Nuklearwaffen
kleine nuklear auch eine sogenannte
taktische Atombombe ist eine
verheerende Waffe absolut also ich gebe
ihm mal ganz konkretes Beispiel die B61
die Bombe die in Büchel lagert die wir
in dem Rahmen der nuklearen Teilhabe
Deutschlands ja auch sozusagen mit den
USA gemeinsam unter Umständen verbringen
müssen die hat sogar sowas nennt man
teilhielt also man kann die
sprengenwirkung einstellen mit einem
Drehschalter auf vier Stufen
0,1 Kilotonnen eine Kilo Tonne 5 und so
um die 40 so 40 Kilo Tonnen da sind wir
bei der doppelten Sprengwirkung von der
Bombe die Hiroshima zerstört hat doppelt
so viel doppelt so viel wie die und wir
reden jetzt immer noch von sogenannten
taktischen Atomwaffen und das sollte die
sozusagen jedem klar vor Augen stehen
dass das keine kleine Sache ist so
natürlich haben wir eben strategischen
Bereich da geht's dann um die
interkontinental Raketen sozusagen
springen Wirkung die auch so bis zum
Megatonnen gehen ähm das stimmt schon
aber man darf sich da eben sozusagen
keine falschen Vorstellungen machen
entscheidend ist im Prinzip der
Unterscheidung strategische
Nuklearwaffen sollen Kriege verhindern
die sollen ja nicht eingesetzt werden
die sind ja nur dazu da sich gegenseitig
damit zu bedrohen damit niemand auf die
Idee kommt tatsächlich mal eine zu
benutzen und die taktischen sollen eben
auf dem Gefäß fällt tatsächlich
irgendwas machen
weitgehend ist man aber eigentlich in
der nahto davon abgekommen ja also für
uns spielen die keine großen Rolle keine
große Rolle mehr in in Russland ist es
eben deswegen anders weil dieses dieses
Gefechts atomare Gefechtsfeld Dispositiv
dazu dient konventionelle Schwäche
auszugleichen und das steht uns auch ins
Haus weil man die russischen
Landstreitkräfte werden ja quasi
aufgerieben in der Ukraine gerade das
heißt wir müssen damit rechnen dass
Nuklearwaffen diese taktischen Waffen in
Zukunft noch größere Rolle spielen
werden einfach als ja Balance dazu dass
man konventionell schon so viel
eingebaut okay also okay das ist jetzt
nicht wirklich beruhigend was Sie da
sagen also das verstehe ich auch diesen
einen Satz den ich in einem Interview
von ihm gelesen haben wo sie sagten es
ist unglaublich naiv immer so zu tun
auch auch in den Gesprächsrunden
teilweise in Interviews in der
Öffentlichkeit so zu tun als wären
sozusagen diese Atombomben uns jetzt mal
sozusagen keine ernsthafte Option sie
sagen natürlich muss man das ernst
nehmen
ich nehme das ernst ja also ich nehme
das grundsätzlich ernst aber ich sage
gleichzeitig das Risiko ist nicht akut
ja also ich meine für mich ist es eine
Sache mit der ich jetzt auch quasi 20
Jahre mein Berufsleben verbracht habe
also dadurch ist man natürlich auch ein
gewissen Sinne schon deformiert ja ähm
aber ich habe diese Bedrohung immer
wahrgenommen ich habe das oft gemerkt
als der Krieg losging
mit Journalistinnen und Journalisten
telefoniert und zum Beispiel letztes
Jahr gab es diesen Einsatz dieser
kinderrakete das ist eine vom Flugzeug
abgeworfene
ballistische Rakete die wird Hyperschall
schnell also wird eben sehr schnell
schneller als mach
fünffache schallgeschwindigkeiten
und dann war das ein riesen riesiger
Aufreger
80er Jahre Technologie und so und die
ist kann da Raketen die in Kaliningrad
stehen sind in 7 Minuten in Berlin
das wussten meine Gesprächspartnerin im
Gesprächspartner gar nicht also wir
hatten das verdrängt 20 30 Jahre lang
dass diese Bedrohung überhaupt da ist
und dann natürlich war immer klar dass
das Risiko besteht dann kam die Invasion
zweite Angriff Russland auf die Ukraine
letztes Jahr im Februar dann waren ja
von Anfang an diese nuklearen Drohungen
da und dann würde ich sagen ist die
Sache noch mal
ernster geworden im September an dem
Punkt als Putin sagte also ich will
jetzt diese vier Blaster annektieren und
die nukleare Drohung erstrecke ich
explizit auch auf diese das war der
Moment wo er nicht das getan hat was man
hätte tun können nämlich sich umdrehen
und sagen ich deklariere das was ich
erreicht habe als Sieg und verkaufe das
zu Hause entsprechend sondern da hat er
im Grunde den Einsatz erhöht ja und
deswegen ist es aus meiner Sicht nicht
seriös zu sagen es wird nie passieren
und Putin Bluff garantiert
kann man einfach nicht sagen es gibt ein
Restrisiko aber aus den genannten
Gründen die Drohungen nützlicher als die
Tat und so weiter geht nicht davon aus
dass wir eine schlaflose Nächte haben
ist warum hat Putty das damals nicht
gemacht was glauben Sie der hätte doch
einfach sagen können ich gehe da jetzt
raus das ist die Chance sich
zurückzuziehen dem ist klar gemacht
worden wie schwach seine Armee
eigentlich tatsächlich ist man hätte das
trotzdem zu Hause als Sieg verkaufen
können
weil Putin ein extrem schlechter
Stratege ist das ist auch so eine Sache
die haben wir uns eingeredet in den
letzten paar Jahren ich habe das
mehrfach in in verschiedenen
Zusammenhängen immer wieder auch gesagt
hört auf euch einzureden das Putin ein
genialer Strategie ist der viel
dimensionale Schach spielt die ganze
Zeit und uns sozusagen am Nasenring
durch die Magnete für das sagt
er ist ein lausiger Strategie aber ein
sehr cleverer Taktik ja also diese
ganzen Drohungen dieses gezielte
Nadelstiche setzen ja ich meine als dann
letztes Jahr war ja dann in Bali auch
der der G20 gibt
ja genau und dann wurde ja auch
sozusagen von der Weltgemeinschaft auf
Putin relativ klar eingewirkt er sollte
doch bitte nur klare Tore mal ein
bisschen runterfahren unser Kanzler
Scholz hat dann danach gesagt es sei ein
Block eingerannt und das stimmt auch die
Rhetorik hat nachgelassen aber mich z.B
hat im Oktober massiv beschäftigt dieses
Gespenster sogenannten schmutzigen Bombe
das war meine medial sehr präsent und
das war wieder einer dieser Nadelstiche
um zu versuchen diese nukleare Angst am
Laufen zu halten das ist so typisch
typisch Putin ja aber um auf ihrer
Ausgangsfrage zurückzukommen er ist ein
schlechter Stratege also ich meine die
Invasion war ein katastrophaler
strategischer Fehler
was ich gerade beschrieben habe im
September die letzte Möglichkeit sich
dazu nehmen möglicherweise noch
rauszukommen würde ich sagen
strategischer Fehler diese
Winteroffensive jetzt ja wo er den
Befehl haben den General absetzt und
durch den Herrn grassimo versetzt der
jetzt nicht nur generalstoffchef ist
sondern auch zuständig für die für die
Operation für das tägliche Geschäft
sozusagen ja man sieht ja wie es läuft
katastrophal auch verbunden mit so einer
so einer Ungeduld ja ähm offensichtlich
auf seinen Putins und deswegen
ja also dieser Putin der geniale
Stratege der uns alle schlecht aussehen
lässt das habe ich schon länger nicht
gekauft aber wir müssen uns natürlich
gewahr werden
[Musik]
gezeigt gerade in seinen Ausführungen
ich glaube es gibt dann eine sehr tief
sitzende psychologische Komponente wenn
kein putinologe sie haben wunderbare
großartige Russland Kennerinnen schon
auf diesen Stühlen sitzen gehabt besser
erklären
aber so diese Demütigung und dieser
neoimperiale Impuls der scheint bei
Putin eben schon sehr stark
handlungsleitend zu sein
die gute Gelegenheit um einmal sozusagen
die die Runde zu erweitern und die erste
Frage an katja Kipping in dem
Zusammenhang wissen Sie Frau Kipping
weil sie das gerade so kurz andeuteten
da gibt es ja auch die taktischen Waffen
auf deutschem Boden wissen Sie was in
Deutschland wirklich an der atomaren
Waffen ist
wo die sind wie die zum Einsatz kämen
wie das läuft haben sie eine Ahnung
davon wie das geht
ich weiß das ist Waffen auch hierzulande
gibt aber als ich im Bundestag tätig war
war ich im Sozialausschuss nicht im
Verteidigungsausschuss also das ist
jetzt nicht als Bürgerin des Landes gar
nicht als Expertin oder so
unterschiedliche Waffenarten jetzt
auseinanderhalten zu können und
anzunehmen aber das natürlich bekommt
man in den aktuellen Diskussionen die
verschiedensten Überlegungen mit äh ja
genau weil sie gerade sagten wir haben
keinen Bewusstsein dafür wüssten sie das
Alexander wie das wie das läuft wo sind
die wann kommen die zum Einsatz wie
würde das ausgelöst ich hoffe niemals
es gibt das Konzept der nuklearen
Teilhabe genau was was bedeutet also
Deutschland hat ja selber keine
Atomwaffen ist Mitglied des Atomwaffen
schwervertrages ist aber ja unter einem
atomaren Schutzschirm das heißt die
amerikanischen Atomwaffen schützen uns
durch Abschreckung und ein Teil dieser
amerikanischen Atomwaffen liegt auch bei
uns und würde im
katastrophalen Fall wenn das
Wirklichkeit würde auch von deutschen
Flugzeugen transportiert und das klingt
jetzt wie eine Story aus dem Kalten
Krieg war aber politisch sehr evident
weil die Modernisierung dieser Flugzeuge
die die transportieren war politisch
strittig weil in der die große Koalition
wusste dass man eigentlich neue
Flugzeuge beschaffen muss und die SPD
hat das blockiert und hat mit dem Idee
geflirtet man könnte aus dieser
nuklearen Teilhabe aussteigen das hat
Olaf Scholz mit dieser Zeitenwende Rede
abgeräumt es werden auch neue Flugzeuge
bestellt also da ist man sozusagen
drüber weg nur jetzt müsste man sich
eigentlich in dieser Logik den Kopf
machen
vor kurzem dachten wir noch können wir
aussteigen was machen wir wenn die
Amerikaner aussteigen richtig weil das
amerikanische politische System das
Jahrzehnte lang gab es zwei Parteien die
waren sehr unterschiedlicher Meinung
aber in dieser Frage waren sie sich
einig und wenn man sich jetzt angucken
ausgerechnet bei den Republikanern also
den konservativen gibt zu seinen Flügel
der sagt lass die machen da in der
Ukraine und was geht uns der Europäer an
also eigentlich müsste man jetzt die
Überlegung machen was machen wir für den
Fall den Gott verhütet dass sie
Amerikaner nicht mehr für unsere
Sicherheit garantieren wollen und wenn
man sich anschaut was zum Beispiel
Präsident macron der französische
Präsident sagt dann hört man immer
wieder Angebote wollen wir nicht über
eine europäische nuklearverteidigung
nach so dazu muss man wissen dass die
Franzosen ja Atomwaffen haben und bis
jetzt geht die Bundesregierung darauf
nicht ein was ich interessant finde weil
der Gedanke liegt ja eigentlich nahe
wenn die Amerikaner etwas unsicherer
werden haben wir noch andere Partner
und ich glaube dass oder Volks diese
Debatte ein bisschen fürchte
was wir da im Hintergrund sehen Herr
Sauer ist Büchel
gesehen genau was sehen wir da wo ist
das und was was
würde passieren wenn das ist ein
Rheinfalls und dann diese Anlagen die
man da sieht sind eben Bunker und wie
viele genau und wo genau weiß natürlich
niemand sie wissen es schon aber sie
sagen
natürlich Zahlen rumgereicht das sind
einige wenige Dutzend ja von diesen B61
einige wenige Dutzend genau und das ist
wirklich eine Bombe also quasi die hänge
ich an einen Flugzeug das Flugzeug
fliegt die Bombe wird abgebrochen und
die fällt sozusagen durch die
Gravitation nach unten gesteuert gelenkt
oder einfach
da sind sie genau schon sozusagen am
Punkt die sind jetzt gerade im Prozess
modernisiert zu werden die werden jetzt
in das Modell b612 überführt und da
haben die dann jetzt tatsächlich hinten
so eine kleine Steuereinheit und sind im
Prinzip Smart also treffen ihr Ziel
genauer dann kann man natürlich auch die
sprengenwirkungen reduzieren also die
werden tatsächlich modernisiert so wie
eigentlich alle leider muss man sagen
gerade massiv investieren und
modernisieren und da sind die auch von
betroffen so und die Idee war eben dass
der alte Tornado diese Waffen aufnehmen
würde und im Fall der Fälle noch mal die
Idee ist vollkommen richtig erklärt
worden war wir wollen diese Waffen nie
einsetzen aber dadurch dass wir sie
haben signalisieren wir sozusagen
Russland wir könnten ergo sehen wir
beide davon ab ja
die Idee wäre eben gewesen der Tornado
nimmt die auf fliegt wirft sie ab im ich
komme aus Hessen im Fulda GAP ja also
das war ja sozusagen die große Gefahr
dass man nicht da kommen riesige
Panzerverbände durch Rollen da sozusagen
über die deutsch-deutsche Grenze und
dazu waren diese taktischen
Nuklearwaffen ursprünglich mal gedacht
vor vielen Jahren so und dann natürlich
durch diese schönen Entwicklungen die
wir ja genossen haben in den letzten 30
Jahren wo wir eigentlich wieder hin
wollen
wir von Freunden umzingelt und mit dem
Tornado hätte man Bomber bombardieren
können im Prinzip nur noch unsere
Partnerin Verbündeten ja also der hätte
gar nicht mehr die Reichweite gehabt und
das ging natürlich schon früher los okay
verstehe ja ja weil das Flugzeug kommt
und ähm
deswegen war die nukleare Teilhabe eben
auch militärisch umstritten ja weil
sozusagen in Instrument mit dem ich
nicht glaubwürdig drohen kann ist ja
nicht abklappt so und deswegen die
Diskussion geht eigentlich schon länger
zurück ich kann mich noch erinnern das
müsste so 2010/2011 gewesen sein Herr
Westerwelle der hatte damals auch so
diesen Punkt also Außenminister war zu
sagen hey ist das nicht ein reliktes
Kalten Krieges könnten wir das nicht
vielleicht möglicherweise mal ad acta
legen also da erinnere ich mich noch
sehr sehr gut ja und dann kam 2014 die
Annexion und dann haben auch Menschen
wie ich die nun sehr kritisch auch auf
Nuklearwaffen blicken und die durchaus
auch für problematisch halten wenngleich
sie natürlich für die Abschreckung
dienlich sind also ab 2014 hat haben
auch Leute wie ich gesagt nukleare Teil
habe jetzt vermutlich vom Timing her
keine gute Idee da auszusteigen gut und
jetzt ist der alte Tornado sowieso
Geschichte und wir kriegen die F35 aus
den USA wie weit
die kann man die kann die hat die
Reichweite um Ziele zu erreichen
Baltikum etc auftankfähigkeit in der
Luft so und jetzt ganz konkret also die
Staaten jetzt den Büchel mit diesen Atom
springen Köpfen Smart wie sie sagen also
die können gesteuert werden müssen dann
irgendwo weil sie nicht an ein Ziel
innerhalb Russlands erreichen wer fliegt
die sind das amerikanische Piloten sind
deutsche Piloten deutsche Luftwaffe ja
die Idee dabei ist bei dieser
nuklear-anteil habe ist eine sogenannte
zwei Schlüssel Lösung die nukleare
Teilhabe ist auch nicht ganz unhaarig
also da wird natürlich wenig drüber
gesprochen aber
Robin alexander hat es gesagt wir
Deutschland und die USA natürlich auch
haben wir den Nuklearwaffen nicht
verbreitungsvertrag unterschrieben und
zwar dieses Vertrags den fast alle
Staaten der Welt teilen dürfen fünf
Staaten USA Russland China
Großbritannien in Frankreich
Nuklearwaffen haben und die dürfen die
nicht weitergeben
deswegen hat die USA diese Waffen auch
nicht weitergegeben die liegen eben in
Büschel und für den Fall der Fälle
können die mit deutschen Flugzeugen
verbracht werden in denen deutsche
Piloten sitzen aber beide müssen den
Schlüssel drehen das ist so eine Art
sozusagen juristischer Trick um um den
um diesen Vertrag herum zu arbeiten und
zu sagen wir geben euch die Waffen aber
ihr habt sie nicht wirklich konkret das
würde so laufen also das sagt man sowas
so grundsätzlich wird das sozusagen so
ist es vorgesehen das ist im Prinzip
eine Fähigkeit die vorgehalten wird das
wird auch trainiert also das ist so und
noch mal ich würde es mir auch wünschen
wir würden sozusagen jetzt in einem
Europa leben wo wo wir von deutschen
Dingen Abstand nehmen könnten aber es
ist absolut nicht okay so und eben ist
so so ganz nebenbei von von Robin
Alexander etwas gefallen der hat auf
Frankreich hingewiesen
und sag dem macron bringt das immer
wieder ins Spiel und das klingt dann
immer so ein bisschen der fast schon ein
bisschen selbstlos und nach dem Motto
wir die Franzosen wir sind so nett und
kümmern uns dann um euch mit und
eigentlich um ganz Europa ich bin mir
gar nicht so sicher dass das wirklich so
selbstlos ist dieser Tage gab es ein
Interview mit Juri Schweiz ehemaliger
Agent KGB oder FSB der ukrainischen
Fernsehen sagte ich vermute stark wie
auch andere Fachleute dass die
Atomwaffen in Russland gar nicht mehr
wirklich existieren
Quatsch ja das Interview hat mir viel
Arbeit gemacht
[Gelächter]
also wenn etwas zu schön klingt um wahr
zu sein das ist in aller Regel eben
nicht wahr
also ich habe ihn nicht so verstanden
dass er sagt die existieren nicht mehr
funktionieren
genau es wird auch so die Geschichte
kolportiert Russland hätte sich aus new
start oder hätte new start diesen
Rüstungs kontrollvertrag der Jungs
suspendiert wurde von Russland hätte das
getan weil es sozusagen aufgefallen wäre
so langsam dass da nur noch Spinnenweben
an den nuklear springen können und die
alle nicht mehr funktioniert die Frage
kann man relativ einfach beantworten
6.000 ungefähr Sprengköpfe in Russland
ich sage deswegen ungefähr weil wir bei
diesen bei diesen Gefechtsfeld Waffen
gar nicht genau wissen wie viele die
haben die sind von keinem
rüstungskontrollen Vertrag erfasst aber
bei den strategischen wissen willst das
sind 1.550 die einsatzfähig sind
einsetzbar sind und dann gibt es welche
auf Lager und in Summe sind das so 6000
wenn davon 90% nicht funktionieren
reichen die letzten zehn Prozent aus für
alles ja
das ist
wirklich ich würde ich hätte gerne so
aber das sollte man sich nicht drauf
verlassen ich ich ich war mal im Moment
vor vor Jahren habe dort gesehen wie in
welchen abgelegenen Fjorden dann auch
solche eu-boote liegen und so weiter
Atom u-bote wenn man das so sieht in
welchem Zustand die sind wie das
offenkundig gewartet wird und so weiter
will ich das für plausibel und dachte
das kann ich mir schon vorstellen wenn
man sich den gerade am Korruption auch
in der russischen Armee so anschaut
dachte ich könnte sein dass es natürlich
ein Argument wenn sie sagen Prozent
davon reichen auch wir sagen 6.000 sind
das im Vergleich dazu die Amerikaner wie
viel haben die paar weniger insgesamt ja
da sind wir glaube ich so bei 4 5
aber durch diesen News startvertrag ist
es ja ohnehin so geregelt dass die
beiden sich auf Obergrenzen verständigt
haben für Sprengköpfe das nennt man die
ployable dafür gibt es leider keine gute
Übersetzung das ist sowas wie
einsatzfähig operativ also welche die
man tatsächlich im Grunde von jetzt auf
gleich verschießen könnte ja da gibt es
eine Obergrenze 1550 auf beiden Seiten
und Trägersysteme also jetzt nehme ich
gerade einen U-Boot beispielsweise die
werden damit gemeint Bomber und
natürlich interkontinental Raketen die
in Silos stecken oder Russland oder
fährt die gerne auf der Straße rum oder
durch die Wälder so und ja also 1550
strategische Sprengköpfe
ich war okay da brauchen wir gar nicht
weiter drüber reden also das sind
Obergrenzen aber das sind natürlich
immer noch Obergrenzen die okay völlig
okay absurd sind ja schon klar und
letzte Frage nehmen Zusammenhang bevor
wir dann gleich auch über die Frage
reden sollten wir dafür sorgen dass die
aus Büchel wegkommen oder nicht
was ja trotzdem einleuchtet ist das muss
ja alles gewartet werden das muss ja in
Schuss gehalten werden um erstmal diesen
Begriff an dem Punkt zu benutzen
was kostet das wie aufwendig ist das wie
oft muss das gemacht werden und ist das
der Hintergrund auch warum man sagt lass
uns doch zusammen machen weil dann
können uns die Kosten für diesen
Wahnsinn teilen das ist durchaus glaube
ich ein Motiv und darin ist auch glaube
ich eigentlich nichts unlauter und ich
meine sogar gab auch deutsche Politiker
ich glaube Wolfgang Schäuble z.B der
immer sehr klar gesagt hat ja gut dann
machen wir das ja also dann beteiligen
wir uns wie viel wollt ihr haben wir
schreiben den Scheck und dann guck mal
dass wir uns da zusammenraufen und das
ist auch nicht ganz ganz abwegig ne weil
Frankreich ist ja nun die einzige noch
verbliebene nuklear Macht in der EU
Großbritannien ist nicht mehr in der EU
das heißt sozusagen das Kräfte
Gleichgewicht hat sich da verschoben
für Deutschland ist sowas natürlich
immer haarig weil wir sind nicht die
Franzosen die Franzosen
wollen Souveränität französische
Souveränität klar alles selber machen
alles selber können und sie wollen
europäische Souveränität nicht alleine
bezahlen ja genau und für uns ist
natürlich die NATO mit der nuklearen
Teilhabe und so das heißt wir müssen das
politisch müssen wir das Ausbauen und
ziehen sowas aber auch das klang jetzt
schon mal an was machen wir wenn im
weißen 2024 so ja dann müssen wir uns
unter Umständen mit diesem französischen
Vorschlag Nummer 9 okay und um mal weiß
man das was kostet das die Amerikaner
zum Beispiel um dieses gigantischer
Atomwaffen Arsenal einfach so zu halten
zu betreuen das ist notfalls auch
funktioniert was was geben die dafür aus
sehr sehr viel Geld also ich 40 50
Milliarden Dollar das heißt also ich
würde ja oder wie ja ich würde mal sagen
also die USA geben allein um ihre
nuklear Streit macht dieses Dispositiv
aufrecht zu halten einfach so viel aus
wie Länder wie Deutschland für ihre
gesamte Streit macht also das ist extrem
viel Geld und in den USA muss man auch
sagen ist es insofern leicht übertrieben
weil sie diese sogenannte Triade haben
also sie haben sägestützte Waffen
Interkontinentalraketen in Silos und
Bomber das braucht man gar nicht wenn
man Frankreich und Großbritannien
anguckt die haben vielleicht zwei oder
nur ein Bein von dieser trial ja es
reicht völlig wenn man deswegen sage ich
1555 Sprengköpfe ist zu viel eigentlich
es reicht völlig wenn man 3 bis 400
Sprengköpfe hat die aufgetauchten
U-Booten auf den Weltmeeren unterwegs
sind und das ist die ultimative
Rückversicherung dieses U-Boot ist
versteckt niemand weiß wo es ist wenn
das eigene Land angegriffen wird weiß
der Angreifer im Zweifel könnte eins
dieser U-Boote mich beschießen die
ultimative Lebensversicherung die
Rückversicherung das reicht als
minimaler Abschreckung um diesen
strategischen Gedanken der Abschreckung
eigentlich
gerecht zu werden aber in den in Amerika
ist alles größer und man muss gucken um
auf macron zurückzukommen der
französische Verteidigungshaushalt ist
ungefähr vergleichbar mit unserem 50
Milliarden ungefähr oder genau und da
ist in Frankreich die Charade Gold mit
dabei dabei also
und da ist ein komplettes nuklear
Dispositiv dabei ja mit
sägestützten Raketen und mit
luftgestützen Raketen also auch nukleare
Marschflugkörper okay also Frankreich
leichtes leistet sich da schon natürlich
ganz andere Größenordnung auch und
schafft es irgendwie mit demselben
Betrag solche Dinge auch zu finanzieren